foreign
Hunter and Keeper of the keys at NASA's
exoplanet archive
in March 2022 we reached a major
milestone in space exploration
5 000 known exoplanets
for thousands of years we've wondered
about planets outside of our solar
system now called exoplanets but our
technology only recently caught up with
our imaginations
and yes 5 000 planets is incredible
what's even more incredible is how space
research will change as a result
when I started grad school there were
about a hundred known exoplanets all
radically different from the earth and
from each other
I was determined to find more
I spent four years looking at nearly 87
000 Stars One by One
now you might have this romantic idea
that I was gazing intently through a
telescope pondering some gorgeous view
of the universe
I was not
I was looking at data like this
measuring the brightness of each star
over time
if the brightness dipped just briefly
just a little bit it could be because a
planet had orbited in front of that star
blocking some of the light from reaching
my telescope
so I spent four years looking for
decimal level changes in these data and
after four years I'd found
nothing
zero exoplanets
thankfully they still gave me the PHD I
think for effort
then I moved to Harvard where I worked
on my first NASA mission called epoxy
I still didn't find any exoplanets
then in March 2010 I joined the Kepler
Mission NASA's Grand experiment with
putting one of our planet hunting
instruments into space
Monday was my first day on the base in
Silicon Valley it was mostly spent in HR
Tuesday I sat down and looked at the
data for the first time
and I found my first exoplanet
[Music]
a few minutes later I found another one
there's a saying that we're the
generation that was born too late to
explore Earth and too soon to explore
space
that's not true anymore
that day and every day since I've gotten
to explore space
Kepler made it possible for us to
measure Stellar brightness much more
precisely than we had before and
eventually I helped find thousands of
exoplanets
and we've really only searched our local
corner of the Galaxy to find those
planets that means there's likely tens
of billions of planets just in our Milky
Way
now with so much data we can start
sorting and grouping and categorizing
these planets to find Trends
think of it this way
if you wanted to learn about dogs and
you had five dogs in your study well
you'd learn a lot about those five dogs
that they're all good dogs but maybe not
about dogs in general
if you had five thousand dogs in your
study then you'd start to see that there
were German Shepherds and Dobermans and
beagles and that these different breeds
have different features
with demographic level data on
exoplanets we can start asking some of
these big questions for the first time
like of those thousands and billions of
planets in our galaxy how many are like
the Earth
or like Jupiter
how many planets does a typical star
have
can a planet orbit more than one star
yes
can a planet exist without any Star at
all
also yes
one surprising result from the study of
planet populations is that the most
common kind of planet in our galaxy
might be one we don't have in our solar
system a super Earth up to twice as big
and 10 times as heavy as our Earth
we've found evaporating planets
disintegrating planets planets clustered
together in A Clockwork dance Ultra
puffy planets ultra dense planets it's
truly a wild and wonderful Menagerie
that I get to Corral at the NASA exquana
archive
but it gets even more interesting than
that with so much data we might finally
be able to figure out how planets are
made
we see baby Stars being born in Stellar
nurseries surrounded by dust and gas
and we see all the stars surrounded by
completed planetary systems but we still
don't really know what happens in
between
with more data we might find planets at
some middle stage or many middle stages
and from there be able to map out a
timeline of planetary development
what triggers these diffuse clouds of
dust and gas to collapse and transform
and how does the chaos and turmoil of
dust become Pebbles and Pebbles become
Boulders and boulders become
planetismals and from there after an
intense series of bombardments
eventually settle into an ordered series
of planets
how often is one of those planets solid
and warm with a water ocean lapping a
Sandy Shore
where do we come from and how did we get
here
the more we learn about exoplanets the
easier it is to Target the ones we want
so far we haven't found any planets that
are like the Earth but I hope we will
NASA just spent the last few years
studying the idea of a very large
telescope in space with Next Generation
technology that would allow us to take
an image an actual photograph of a
planet like the Earth
with that photo we could search for
biomarkers signatures of life
I'll probably spend the rest of my
career working on that mission I hope I
get to take that photo
thank you
[Applause]